There are many kinds of animals.
Elk run fast.
Elk live in the mountains.
Giraffes are tall.
Giraffes have spots.
Elephants are strong.
Elephants have long trunks.
Camels live in deserts.
Camels can go without water for a long time.
Foxes have bushy tails.
Foxes live in holes in the ground.
Zebras have stripes.
Zebras live in grassy places.
Hippos live near water.
Hippos have almost no hair.
Polar bears live in cold places.
Polar bears eat seals.
There are many kinds of animals.
Let's read storybooks!
Okay. I like to read about animals.
Look. There is a bear in the cave.
There are two bears near water.
Look at this. There is a monkey in the tree.
Wow, it is so cute!